[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
ha
[Music]
[Music]
lay down another bar
what are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
His Majesty the King has arrived temple
were warned you way behind temple or
what be warned their royal and
possession started from the grand palace
compound going towards rush damn noon
Avenue before turning to proceed to the
but one evade road and the Royal
palanquin of His Majesty stopped on the
side of bonnie raitt Lee hun tempo now
that His Majesty is graciously proceeded
to pay respect to the Buddha image here
at Bonnie Baili Han temple Kaupapa
Tichina ze
which is there in the ordination Hall of
what one he then will pay homage to the
Royal ashes of his royal ancestors here
as well
the ordination hall or the opposite
insurance to large golden buddha images
seated on pedestal is what born is
principal buddha image the prepetition
assay the sukhothai style image in the
calling the earth to witness posture was
mold in thirteen thirteen fifty seven
originally enshrined in the word
president and at muhurta temple in peace
in law the image was moved to what the
one who ate in the early 19th century
the image is flanked by two static
images in adoration seated in front of
the cottage in the sea or three small
images of former parts of the temple
behind it is another larger Buddha image
named non-patent
this is the first temple that the royal
and possession stopped and the whole
distance of the royal land procession
today is about seven kilometers or
around four point three miles in
distance of all three temples but one
away behind temple known in short as
what the Bonnie wait or what the one is
the royal temple of the first great
Butte in the third reign
it is an important center for the Tama
Huata sect so a former ibattz here went
on to become the supreme patent of
thailand this temple was the residence
of the kings of the royal house of the
green when he they enter the monkhood
the royal ashes of king king rama ignite
the King Rama the six are enshrined
under the base of Papa Tichina see
Buddha image in the ordination Hall of
what the one King Rama 10 stay in this
temple during his monkhood in 1978
once again you're watching the second
day of the coronation of King Rama 10th
starting from yesterday which yesterday
was the most important and significant
part of the procedure of the coronation
the crow nation will last together for
three days and today this is the first
temple that the royal position royal
line procession stopped there will be
another two temples which is
what washable pit and what potato corn
or the reclining budda temple
talking about what I warn you every hand
the temple precincts so generally but
this monasteries are typically divided
into two sections
pootabot or the sanctuary buildings and
structures devoted to the buddha such as
the opposite hall or stupa and some
kawatte or the section containing
residential dwellings for monks and
novices another bland word of what
Bhagwan is poor three house so the poor
three is a species of three that
protected the Buddha during his final
struggle for liberation ultimately
leading to the highest victory for that
reason the poor tree is a symbol of the
Buddha's awakening and he is referenced
on a level equal to that of a Buddha
image or a Buddha footprint
according to thai royal tradition and
the king of thailand should have his
royal temple after the coronation but so
on this is one of them the royal temples
for the king in the decree dynasty the
temple is located just outside the old
city wall or pass main and the old name
is what mine the temple had is first
monastic battery in 1829 King Rama 3
asked his brother to be an Abbott in the
temple in 1832 so this is the Buddha
image of Papagena see when dum where the
Royal ashes of his Majesty's ancestors
has been enshrined
and as you watching here the was thought
or the ordinary Hall ordination hall
entrance to large quarter Buddha images
right here
seated on a pedestal in the one per one
principle Buddha image the Propontis in
SAE the Sukhoi high style image in the
calling the earth to witness posture was
mode in 1357 originally enshrined in
what was a rotten Atma had her temple in
prison la Provence the image was moved
to what were worn in the early 19th
century as you can see the image is
flanked by two standing images in
adoration and seated in front of the
prepetition se you can see three small
images of former a part of the temple
behind it is another large buddha image
named lump at all
this is the temple of King Rama six and
this is better Buddha image Papa
Tennessee has been enshrined in the
ordination hall along with venerable
monk statues earlier
it matches the King brought in coding
Putin or the warrior plinking in the
Royal line possession during the city
tour of three major temples this is the
first temple of the royal and possession
to stop what Bhavani where we hon Nolan
short ass what boob one is a royal
temple of the first grade built in the
third brain it is an important Centre
for the Tamil youth sector and several
former Abbot's here went on to become
the supreme patek of thailand the temple
was a resin of the kings of the royal
house of chakri when they enter mount
hood the royal ashes of King Vimala
sticks enshrined under the base of the
protogynous a Buddha image in the
ordination Hall of what our only King
Rama tenth state in Hill in this temple
during his monkhood in 1978 within a
while the Royal land possession will
move to another important temple which
is what--right a ball pit earlier we
witnessed that there have been the royal
families the members of the Royal
Family's awaiting for the royal land
along their Russian demoon Avenue right
so as dr. room kept mentioned that day's
tempo has strong ties with the royal
family and you are witnessing here one
of the most important structure of what
bhiwani way JD the temples most
noticable structure is the 50 meter high
cordon JD or stupa it's most important
structure of the temple since it
enshrines sacred relics the JD sits on
an elevated base with a lower and upper
terrace the lower Terrace contains
depictions of celestial beings from
Hindu mythology at each of the corners
of the terrace is a small prong in
training an image of the Buddha in
dispelling fear mudra the temple has its
first monastic boundary in 1829 when
King Rama the 3rd asked his brother who
was among and Bert Rashad he want to be
an Abbott to the temple in 1832 later
King Rama 3rd renamed the temple - what
Bhavani wait Rehan in order to announce
that this was a royal mount temple and
the abbot of the temple would later be
King Rama the 4th
so when King Rama the 4th was an a bird
at what Bhavani ready hon he introduced
Dominique nicaya or a sect or in
Buddhism to Thai monks King Rama 4th set
up examples for all the monks in the
temple to follow when he was among
himself the Tumblety guy has more strict
rules of conduct for the monks the
temple has so many bird
related arts works and objects for both
Buddhists and monks to appreciate and
learn the temple also has a bridge to
separate monks area and merit makers so
they could follow strict rules of
community some of you may have been to
these important temples what our journey
is situated not too far from the the
Grand Palace and is one of the most
visited or forum for the Thai people
ourselves the temple is also considered
as one of the major temples as we
mentioned earlier that some of the
supreme Preta of thailand used to reside
here this is the first-class royal
temple presiding the buddha image the
proper touch in the sea and also has
another buddha image call papa
the one a kid in the back and as you can
see from the screen right now the GU
basalt or the coordination hall was
built during the reign of king rama the
third the entrance door is richly
decorated with God carvings depicting
guardians
Neuros from the second half of the 19th
century depict stories from the Buddhist
teachings and once again this is JD or
stupa the temples most noticable
structure with 50 meters height
the hollow jetty is closed to the public
except on one kalpen Saturday usually in
July inside our five small Gordon cities
that contain sacred relics the central
one is set on a stone base on his four
sides or toppings are four of the most
important events in the life of the
Buddha namely birth enlightenment first
sermon at the Deer Park in SONET and
passing into nirvana waiting in there
the ordination hall here of Bhavani wake
behind temples our venerable month led
by some people and errata a part of the
temple of Bhavani wait in a while his
majesty to pay homage to the Buddha
image and the royal ashes of his royal
ancestors and the monks brush and fast
keep blessing
when we talked about Buddhism in
Thailand Buddhism plays a very
significant role in daily life of Thai
people since more than 90% of our people
here are Buddhist Buddhism in inevitably
involve almost every occasion such as
birthdays marriages moving to new house
opening business offices and also buying
new vehicles for example so um
briefly speaking in Thailand we are
following
Theravada Buddhist belief and one is it
was introduced Buddhism became widely
accepted and gained a permanent ground
in the Kingdom of Thailand the Buddhist
doctrine stresses the three principal
aspects of existence
the first one is touka or suffering the
second one is a neat job which means
impermanence and the third one is
another meaning non substance abstain
non substantiality furthermore the
ultimate aim of Buddhism is nirvana
or in sanskrit Nirvana which literally
means the extinction of our desire and
of all suffering or dukkha it is an end
not only to suffering an action of karma
but also to the cycle of rebirths that
is existent Buddhism plays an important
role within their daily life of Thai
people there more than 27,000 Buddhist
temples across the country a majority of
them are in the countryside in Thailand
Buddhist monks are
venerated for their just live
self-restraint social benevolence and
knowledge of spiritual practice so to
allow people to have more time to devote
to religious practices or major Buddhist
holy days are declared as national
holidays in addition it has been a Thai
custom for Buddhist males over 20 years
old to be temporarily ordained as
Buddhist monks usually during the annual
rains retreat so temporarily ordination
ranging from a few days to three months
is open to anyone
once again this is inside the ordination
Hall of what be born or Bonnie ready hon
temple inside a hall members of the
royal families awaiting the arrival of
His Majesty the King to pay homage to
the Buddha image and royal ancestors the
royal ashes of his royal ancestor which
is enshrined underneath da Buddha image
as you can see that what one has a
fascinating structures the Crown's of
what Bhavani way it contains several
prominent buildings residences for
royalty or high-ranking Buddhist monks
originally built in the grand palace the
Platinum ponyo was moved to the what
Bhavani wait by King Rama the third in
1836 to be the residence for Prince
market after he became the a part of the
temple several kings lived in the
predominate ponyo building including the
late King Bhumibol Adulyadej who was
among
in order what bhiwani well for a while
the building is a mix of Thai Chinese
and European styles then the predominate
pet was built by king vajiravudh or King
Rama 6th in 1940 1914 as a residence for
the temples third about the building is
now used for various ceremonies the
predominate pet is a very attractive
building in mix of Thai and European
architectural styles his name translates
to royal diamond residents then the
predominate lung and platinum nokton
were built over a century ago
by order of King Chulalongkorn
previously residences for high-ranking
monks the buildings are now used for
official functions
another important structure of what bond
is the scriptural library near the JD
that you just witnessed earlier is the
hot dry which is the temples switcher
library ancient boxes store that rapido
the ancient Buddhist texts written on
dried palm leaf the hot rice walls are
adorned with moon rose and right here
the Abbasid or ordination hall was built
during the reign of King Rama the third
the entrance door is visually decorated
with cloud carvings depicting Guardians
morales from the second half of the 19th
century depict stories from the Buddhist
teachings but one invade behind temple
is considered as one of the most
important temples for the Chakri dynasty
which is the present dynasty and the
Kingdom of Thailand Kingdom under tens
of the King Rama retains as well and
April 6th marks the anniversary of the
founding of the president's acridine
estate of reach the present ruling
monarch the decree dynasty was founded
by King Rama the first who was born in
1737 and came to the throne on able to
sixth in 1782 the King Rama the first
ruled the country for 28 years during
his reign he consolidated the kingdom in
such a way that there was no further
fear of invasion from enemies King Rama
the first
been praised as an accomplished
statement a lawmaker a poet
inaudible Buddhist now His Majesty King
arrived the ordination hall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
beauty
[Music]
[Applause]
it matches the paid respect to the
Buddha image population ste and the
Royal ashes of his royal ancestor
enshrined in the air Tao what Bhavani
we're behind temple and having
conversation with the abbot of Bhavani
we're behind temple some be poppin or
rot before departing what the one to
proceed to the next temple which is what
rise above it in any moment now the
procession will continue to move a la
presa main road and turn right to
Rotterdam than afternoon passing through
the retina goes in exhibition hall then
it turned left to at sedan road and
maroon road next the Royal palanquin
will stop in front of what rots about
pizza did muhammara where His Majesty
will enter to pay homage to the main
buddha image in the ordination hall or
the episode
what Bhiwani bait behind is the
first-class royal temple this is where
the buddha image of pappataci nnessee
was presiding in front and a puta
so when a kid is presiding in the back
this is a temple of king rama the sick
and in a while the royal and possession
who leave their money behind temple
going towards the direction of raja babu
temple which is right across on the
other side of the grand palace
earlier I mentioned about chapter II day
that the king Brahma the first who
founded the Chakri dynasty and when he
came to the throne on April the 6th 1782
King Rama the first ruled the country
for 28 years and on chakra day we
consider every April the 6th of eighty
year is the national holiday in Thailand
and the king of the present king of
Thailand well and along with the members
of the royal family will preside over a
religious ceremony performed to give
married to the diseased rulers at the
Royal Chapel then pays respect to his
majesty
but his sisters at the Royal Pantheon
and lays a wreath and the statue of King
Rama the first and the memorial bridge
on this occasion the Prime Minister
ministers high-ranking officers students
publics foreign private organizations
and people from all walks of life take
part in a wreath-laying ceremony and
make merit for the great kings who
dedicated the best part of their life
for the betterment of their subjects
as we mentioned earlier that what Bawang
has strong ties with the royal family in
1836 Prince market became the first a
part of the temple which he remained
until 1851 when he was crowned King Rama
the fourth several other members of the
royal family lived in the temple
including the late King Bhumibol
Adulyadej or King Rama denies and His
Majesty King Rama the Thames stayed in
this temple during his manhood in 1978
this is the first part the first temple
that the Royal LAN procession stopped
for His Majesty the King to pay homage
to the Buddha image and the Royal ashes
of his royal ancestors before departing
for the next temple earlier His Majesty
the King paid respect to the Buddha
image and the Royal relics before having
then having the conversation with the
abbot of what Bhavani we're sitting on
the left hand side some the power Narada
who also participated in chant prayers
throughout the coronation of King Rama
hence this is one of the most important
royal temples and the Kingdom of
Thailand and it is the first stop of the
royal and possession that's right and
right here inside the episode or the
ordination Hall insurance to large
golden buddha images seated on a
pedestal in the what Bhavani where's
principle Buddha image the proper
Tichina see is the sukhothai style image
in the calling earth to witness posture
it was mowed in 1357 originally
enshrined in the wat procedure a tane
mahuta temple in peace a new law
province the image was moved to the wat
bowon niwet in the early 19th century
the image is flanked by two standing
images in adoration and seated in front
of the prepetition ac3 small images of
former episode temple be heard it is
another larger Buddha image named long
Pato
the time the time in Thailand now is
nearly 7 o'clock 7 p.m. it is 4 to 7
p.m. in Thailand as the Royal land
possession started after 4:30 p.m.
living from the grand palace compound -
stopped here at Bhawani wait behind
temple let me remind you of the royal
possession once again that His Majesty
King Rama 10 sitting on the royal plane
Queen call put band home or golden put
on later on the royal and possession
proceeded towards the direction of
Russia damn moon Avenue the most
beautiful Avenue in Thailand and to
arrive here and a 1e bear behind temple
there will be two more temples which is
Russia Bo Peep temple at another temple
is more proceed upon order reclining
buddha's temple so earlier we witnessed
the first root of the royal and
procession as dr. Antibes mentioned from
the grand palace the procession came out
from upon p more pavilion through with
HIC gate then it turned right to nab
rollin road to left to rotterdam nanai
avenue turned right to rotterdam 9 :
avenue and then turned left to the now
road before moving towered what Bhavani
where
earlier the Royal palanquin stopped in
front of what mewar new wave where His
Majesty the King entered to pay homage
to the main Buddha image in the
ordination Hall the temple of the born
or what Bhagwan is located just inside
the old city wall on the main road next
to run seats tawa temple and this is the
temple of the king by matter 6 and this
is where the royal ashes of the His
Majesty ancestor has been enshrined
we just saw the people that hi people
wearing yellow shirts waiting outside of
what bhiwani we're behind so they are
wearing yellow because is the color
associated with the day of the Kings
birth which is Monday in Thailand every
day of the week corresponds to a color
yellow was also the birth color of the
Kings late father Kimba modernize and
also the Thai government has encouraged
the public to wear this hue over the
coronation period
this the meaning of Bhawani baby hon
tempo is a temple of excellent abode
here once again people from all walks of
life gather awaiting the arrival of His
Majesty the King and there are the
gentlemen's here wearing um he has a
scarf scarf and hat the blue hat
they are the volunteers under the
patronage of His Majesty the King these
volunteers were they are helping to
organize the crowd here you may see that
there are people's come from everywhere
this is along the rush dum known Avenue
not far from the war Newberry Han temple
once again back to the grand palace the
backdrop beautiful and magnificent
backdrop of the city of angel and this
is their the old area of Bangkok or
another name is Rattanakosin Island
which is where we are right now and most
of the
the Royal land possession is going to to
pass all the importance of landmarks of
the Rattanakosin Islands and here inside
the ordination Hall of Bologna where we
hunt impose our members of royal
families as well as the cabinet members
and earlier we also seen though the
important figures here who other present
of National Legislative Assembly Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court are also
prison here
the two gentlemen earlier were also
participated in now
the coronation of King Rama 10
perform the anointment there and other
ceremonies in the grand palace compound
as we can see here the clouds of loyal
citizens wearing yellow they are again
massing around the openings of Bangkok
since this Sunday morning His Majesty
the King to proceed to the Royal plan
Queen and in a while we'll be departing
what bhiwani weight behind temple going
towards the second stop which is
Russia Bo Peep temple
so the procession will continue to move
along impressive main road and turns
right to rotterdam 9 avenue passing
through the Rattanakosin exhibition hall
then it had left to a sedan road and
aluminum road the Royal product.when
stops in front of what collapsible apron
is Magesty will enter to pay homage to
the main with the image in the
ordination home
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
welcome one
[Music]
[Music]
reward
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]